so if I bounce if I
go if I do that
or hang on stabilize
myself that's still not knowing where I
should go because I'm trying to get it
right but I'm I'm sort of vacant I'm I'm
sort of going lift up every timing
whoops hang on right I'm here now I'm
ready you see that's me me me
me if you think about it it's me me me
I'm I'm just trying to work out all the
places I need to be if I actually
go see to
me the hard part is Jenny moved me so if
you can get there well done we can all
be seventh Downs today instantly just
think about
that but that's why I decided to empty
my mind and you actually start knowing
what Tony Sergeants mind works how it
thinks about things but I've been doing
this for like 20 odd years this process
but I realized I can't keep getting you
on the mat on a normal seminar and I
go to make sure you turn the hand for
the
K and then you step out and you throw on
K but you see I'm doing nowadays I'm
doing the same where you're going
through the stage up go I'm move there
well I got it you're not thinking about
do I feel too close to it or could I say
to Jenny oh please go I can say to Jenny
please go past but she will feel if
she's sensitive enough she will feel
that I'm still a little bit too close to
her can you feel that I'm just a little
bit in our
space and yet look everything
technically is
okay and and and I can sense that as I
say you've all got it it's just that you
you're I'm trying to get you to heighten
it I'm trying to get you to heighten it
so when you do
K that's better isn't it mhm but I can
still reach your
hand so so when you
stagger that's an excellent place to be
because it's showing you that you're
actually not flowing your stepping
you're you're sort of choosing then you
go was a bit out of timing there so your
timing's out you're not working with
your partner you're working under your
ready steady go now all right so there's
nothing wrong with that is there any
other questions s yeah um what about the
connection between you and the partner
and whether you you're kind of inviting
them in or right okay all right so
here's another good question so what I'm
going to do is all the people here I
want I want you to just sort of quickly
scan is that belongs me right right
right choose
one why did you choose him probably
because he's nearest to me right so that
yeah right no that's right that's all on
my notes here he chose him because
probably he the nearest one to him
that's why when John said this stagger
bit you see you're not using your
intuition see if I go like that and I S
check everybody out I'm get what what
I'm getting I'm getting right I'm
getting I'm getting you you're quite got
good energy cuz you're drawing me a lot
I get Co he's all right I've noticed him
and then I'm going and I go oh Raj is
the one I want so I don't know why but
I've chosen Raj so you know you do this
without knowing it you go on a big
seminar where you don't really know many
people and you bow in front of somebody
don't you what makes you bow to them
sometimes because they're near you but
another time for some reason their eyes
will catch your eyes and you just go
don't so do you know what I mean by that
have you been have you done that and you
don't know why you've bowed to them but
you bowed to you might have had a really
nice training you might not had such a
nice training so this is the
intuition we need that
to get to the
bridge so so this is a good explanation
of same as John's if I'm going to draw
you in then it's me being doing me again
you I mean I'm the I'm now guay if I go
please Soo I don't expect you to get
what what I'm saying but I can still
reach him
pressing so what I mean I got him at the
right
distance if I want you know you remember
the Bruce Lee half inch punch or
whatever it's a similar
thing I
didn't you if he does it again and I go
here I could do it and say oh I done it
for the camera that would then be me me
me and I would have lost contact with
him if I want to entice him in I'll
go don't more and then I got that little
stagger you see because it was me again
it wasn't him instructing
me here I'm too close all right but I
know I'm too close so if you push in see
that hard wall yeah okay so I was too
close so I'm trying to show you so each
time just talk to each other
they test you you test them is it a hard
wall is it a soft wall you know and and
and then search your head and go well I
don't know how to find it cuz you got to
go through that I don't know how to find
it I don't know what he's talking
about so that means that you're not
looking by not using your eyes if you
look with your eyes you're you'll always
be nuggy you'll always have your timing
wrong